madame monsieur bonsoir la presse de son
pays le qualifier alternativement deux
grands leaders de chefs génial et bien
aimé de héros bienfaiteur du peuple ou
encore de soleil de la corée kim il sung
est mort à 82 ans après avoir régné sans
partage sur la corée du nord durant 46
ans record mondial de longévité au
pouvoir
cet empereur entre guillemets communiste
était l'un des personnages les plus
secrets et les plus inquiétants de
l'histoire contemporaine
stéphane magnier il adorait ses fêtes où
des milliers de petites filles animait
des tableaux humains
c'était le fruit d'une coordination
parfait comme celle que donne un peuple
embrigader depuis l'enfance sous la
férule implacable d'un dieu vivant kim
il sung avaient éradiqué toute
opposition
jusqu à l'ombre d'une contestation il
possède le culte de sa personnalité
encore plus loin peut-être que son
maître staline qui l'avait mis en place
en 1948
kim il sung bâti sa réputation en
faisant la première guerre de l'après
guerre celle de la conquête de la corée
du sud par le nord jusqu'à ce que les
américains interviennent pour amener la
frontière au 38e parallèle puis kim il
sung
les salles entourant son pays glisser
vers la pauvreté et l'isolément absolu
privilégiant l'armée et la bombe
atomique sur la prospérité et la
démocratie il contrôlait tout
l'information l'école les frontières son
peuple est le seul au monde à ne rien
savoir de ce qui se passe ni chez lui ni
ailleurs il est aussi le seul au monde
qui verra naître une monarchie
communiste puisque kim il sung a choisi
son propre fils pour lui succéder
on vient de le dire kim il sung a donc
créé la première dynastie communiste au
monde
son fils kim jong il à 50 ans n'est
jamais sorti de son pays
et certains redoutent qu'il soit tenté
pour préserver son pouvoir par une sorte
de fuite en avant en relançant le
chantage nucléaire mise en place par son
père olivier werner derrière son papa on
le voyait souvent applaudir des deux
mains kim junior
on va sans doute bientôt le voir à
l'oeuvre il dirigeait déjà le parti
l'armée sans pour autant faire
l'unanimité
c'est bien pour ça qu'une certaine
inquiétude règne depuis ce matin en
corée du nord et la romance passé pour
moi je passais où on parle tout est
fermé tout était espéré
certainement dans un mois dans deux mois
on va avoir un peu plus clair mais c'est
à moi au des mois ou trois mois
ce sera extrêmement important non
seulement pour les rapports entre le
nord et le sud mais aussi pour le monde
entier
il y a trois semaines à peine jimmy
carter salué tout sourire le président
nord-coréen
une image qui n'était pas passée
inaperçue aux états unis carter chargé
d'obtenir un gel permanent du programme
nucléaire nord-coréen
en échange de quoi il y aurait
reconnaissance diplomatique et
assistance économique
il ya eu les toute l'ailé pure je pars
avec elle et l'a éliminé physiquement
tous ses adversaires politiques et tout
le régime qu'il a créée la coupé du
monde extérieur qui a freiné
complètement le développement du pays et
qu'elle essayait de sauver son régime
par tous les moyens et compris est donc
actuellement par le chantage nucléaire
le chantage appartient peut-être au
passé 12 informations confirment un
changement d'attitude le sommet prévu
pour le 25 juillet prochain entre les
deux corées est confirmée et puis
américains et coréens du nord vont
poursuivre leurs discussions sur le
nucléaire à genève
kim jong il n'est peut être pas le fils
à papa qu'on croit il ya 50 ans la
guerre de corée faisait plus d'un
million de morts au final un pays séparé
en deux pour mieux comprendre les enjeux
de ce premier sommet retour sur une page
d'histoire avec régis labeaume
c'est le premier conflit brûlant de la
guerre froide nous sommes en 1950 la
guerre de corée vient d'éclater
le nord communiste soutenu par l'union
soviétique de staline et la chine de mao
envahi le sud de la péninsule
l'invasion sera repoussée par les
américains sous le drapeau des nations
unies la guerre dure trois ans et ses
deux millions et demi de morts 1953
l'armistice est signé
désormais le 38e parallèle divise la
corée en deux par une ligne
infranchissable au sud les présidents se
succèdent dans un régime autoritaire
le pays vit sous la protection des
soldats américains
il va connaître de graves crises comme
la révolte des étudiants en 1981 la
marche sera longue avant de parvenir à
la démocratie à la fin des années 90
mais dans le même temps la corée du sud
est devenue une puissance économique et
industriel de premier plan en asie au
nord en revanche rien n'a changé en un
demi siècle de dictature du parti unique
pyongyang est devenu l'un des régimes
les plus sales uniens et fermés au monde
un seul exemple les boutons des postes
de radio sont bloqués sur la radio
nationale vous pouvez pas essayer
d'avoir un autre poste et même à post
chinois je veux dire un post communiste
chinois parade militaire et pulte
extravagant de la personnalité autour de
kim il sung le fondateur avant que kim
jong-il et son fils ne lui succède
car la corée du nord a inventé la
première dynastie communiste
mais avec la chute du communisme
pyongyang a perdu ses derniers appui et
le régime est contraint à rencontrer
pour la première fois les frères ennemis
du sud
le fait que la corée du nord est
acceptée ce sommet indique que la
situation est particulièrement mauvaise
et que la corée du nord acceptent de de
courir un certain danger en se mettant à
la table des négociations
la situation alimentaire est extrêmement
mauvaise car si la corée du nord s'est
lancée dans un programme nucléaire et le
connaît parallèlement une terrible
famine
près de deux millions de personnes
seraient déjà mortes de faim
principalement des enfants
demain la riche et prospère corée du sud
pourrait donc apporter son aide à son
voisin du nord en échange d'une
réunification des familles séparées
depuis plus d'un demi-siècle à pékin
pour la deuxième journée consécutive des
pourparlers se sont engagées entre la
corée du nord et la corée du sud la
famine au coeur des discussions puisque
la corée du nord appelle à l'aide ses
houle pour une aide urgente en effet la
pénurie alimentaire touche l'ensemble de
la population
reportage isabelle bechler et tristan le
braz dam dom est une des portes chinoise
de la corée du nord elle est modeste son
industrie discrète mais semble une ville
en plein boom par rapport à l'exigence
absolue de l'autre rive
même le maho de dandong tourner le dos à
pyongyang
seule bouffée d'oxygène pour la petite
dictature un train par jour et le pont
qui apporte denrées humanitaires et
marchandises a troqué désormais les
routes et chinois doivent emporter leur
gamelle car on trouve plus rien en corée
du
on notera dans l'ivresse rage les gosses
ils me font vraiment pitié chaleureux
bien qu'ils mangent pas à leur faim
il nous attend toujours de l'autre côté
du pont pour nous demander leur reste
on vraiment finir exemple on transporte
une matière première pour le savon c'est
immangeable un produit industriel
les gosses se jette de chiens parce que
ça contient du web même si elle voulait
donner le change la corée du nord ne le
pourrait pas cette frontière
pas une de ses rares cheminées d'usiné
ne fume pas la moindre trace d'activité
à part un vague transbordement çà et là
juste l'hiver le plus lu et le plus
lugubres il semble même que de plus en
plus de corps et un désespéré se
réfugier dans la clandestinité de
famille coréenne de chine car leur état
n'a plus rien à distribuer la ration
quotidienne par cette n'atteint pas 300
g de riz juste de quoi survivre
pas de quoi alimenter la croissance d'un
enfant
c'est à se demander comment ces petits
en sursis trouverait l'énergie de
chanter les autres patriotique quand
leur martèle
et c'est dans les crèches et les écoles
que les enfants c'est encore le mieux
nourris seuls privilégiés l'armée qui
rendent hommage régulièrement à kim
jong-il le fils du défunt dictateur une
arme est toujours prête à en découdre
avec le sud est avec tout l'occident
d'ailleurs une armée enkysté dans la
guerre froide
la situation tragique qu'en corée du
nord ou santa femmes et des centaines de
milliers d'hommes et de femmes victimes
de la pénurie du pouvoir aujourd'hui
l'association action contre la faim a
décidé de quitter le pays
considérant qu'elle n'avait plus de
marge de manoeuvre descente jérôme
benest hiver à nouveau très rude en
corée du nord avec pour les plus démunis
un seul souci qui tourne à l'obsession
survivre loin du regard du monde
les paysans se nourrissent de grains de
riz ou de maïs glanés dans les champs il
traverse des temps très difficiles il y
à peu d'électricité
les coupures sont fréquentes il y a peu
de chauffage le fric on prend quand ils
manquent de nourriture ils ont froid et
ils ont pas fou shopping crocs depuis
trois ans les familles n'ont fait
plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts
en corée du nord
la maigreur des enfants leurs lésions
cutanées sont des signes évidents de
malnutrition eux ont la chance d'être
hospitalisé mais dans des établissements
sans chauffage ni médicaments le cuisine
on prépare une mixture des corses
d'arbres d'herbe ou d'algues ça fait des
pâtes qui remplissent l'estomac
à défaut de vraiment nourrir derrière
ces famines il y a bien sûr
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
principal fournisseur d'énergie qui
entraîna un bond en arrière de
l'agriculture il y a surtout la dernière
dictature stalinienne qui consacre
l'essentiel de ses ressources à l'effort
militaire face au frère ennemi la corée
du sud
l'aide internationale arrive mais c'est
l'état qui la contrôle et la distribuer
de façon discrétionnaire les
organisations humanitaires n'ont pas
leur mot à dire noah travaillant dans
des crèches ou les enfants étaient bien
vêtu bien nourris en bonne santé et tant
mieux mais à la fois nous voyons aussi
dans les rues de la ville où nous
travaillons les en france à l' étude de
haillons vivant près de la gare et nous
nions pas porter assistance à ses
enfants là et cela c'était vraiment très
regrettable
nous avons essayé de proposer aux
autorités un programme de soupe
populaire pour la fois contrôler notre
aide et venir en aide aux populations
les plus démunies
malheureusement ce programme a été
refusé après deux ans sur le terrain
action contre la faim de guerre lasse
quitte la corée du nord ces derniers
mois les tentatives des puissances
occidentales pour rompre l'isolément du
pays n'ont rien apporté à ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin
l'émotion en corée où des familles se
sont retrouvées après plus de 50 ans de
séparation
une centaine de nord-coréens ont pu se
rendre au sud d'autres ont fait le
chemin inverse
nora boubetra au papa si seulement maman
pouvait encore être là à tes copains il
ne s'était pas vu depuis près de 50 ans
ce matin à séoul entre eux il n'y avait
plus ni corée du sud ni corée du nord
quand justin fils qui retrouve un père
âgé aujourd'hui de 91 ans c'est sans
doute le moment le plus fort et le plus
symbolique vers que les coréens appel la
semaine de réconciliation la rencontre
de ces familles la première depuis 15
ans est l'une des mesures clés du
rapprochement décidé en juin dernier
lors du sommet historique entre les
leaders des deux corées retrouver ses
proches les embrasser tous n'ont pas eu
cette chance
aujourd'hui le centre de conférences de
séoul n'acceptait pas plus de cinq
membres par famille qui met donc rester
dehors pour apercevoir son frère
c'est mon frère dans l'ohio
je suis si contente de le voir je pleure
parce que j'étais tellement contente
c'est comme si je rencontrais mon père
et ma mère
aujourd'hui à séoul comme à pyongyang
les mêmes scènes d'émotion
ici aussi c'est une centaine de sud
coréens qui ont fait le voyage pour une
rencontre qui ne durera que quatre jours
quatre jours pour rattraper près d'un
demi-siècle de séparation un premier pas
qui devrait normalement être suivie
d'autres plus de 7 millions et demi de
sud coréens au départ en au nord
totalement à l'opposé maintenant ce
voyage dans le pays le plus fermé du
monde le dernier régime stalinien et son
culte de la personnalité
irréel la corée du nord grande comme 20
départements français 23 millions
d'habitants un homme ou une femme sur 15
en âge de travailler est dans l'armée
l'armée qui monopolisent l'essentiel des
ressources alors qu'on signale
régulièrement des famines
il est extrêmement rare de pouvoir se
rendre en corée du nord l'une de nos
équipes a obtenu un visa
voyage sous bonne escorte c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
philippe rochot et sylvain viau
un spectacle quotidien dans les rues de
pyongyang le retour du soir d'un
détachement de l'armée nord coréenne une
armée d'un million d'hommes
toujours mobilisés face aux états unis
qui soutiennent la corée du sud avec 35
mille soldats passage obligé devant la
statue géante de kim il sung le
fondateur de la république communiste de
corée du nord
il a conduit son pays pendant la guerre
contre le sud et les américains en 1950
huit ans après sa mort il est toujours
vénéré comme un père un dieu son culte
permet de justifier la mobilisation du
dernier régime stalinien de la planète
face aux états unis la corée du nord
accepte rarement la présence de
journalistes étrangers
mais quand on vient ici les autorités
nous empêche le contact avec la
population
on nous pousse plutôt vers les monuments
à cette guerre de corée qui a fait 3
millions de morts est divisé le pays
depuis un demi siècle la guerre sert
encore à justifier les pénuries et les
privations dont sont victimes les
coréens du nord
notre jeune génération n'a pas participé
à cette guerre mais le bonheur de notre
jeunesse aujourd'hui est le résultat du
sacrifice de notre armée populaire et
nous voulons lui enseigner l'histoire le
front n'est qu'à 100 km de pyongyang
pour se rendre à pas de loup john la
dernière frontière de la guerre froide
la route est large elle doit pouvoir
servir de piste d'atterrissage en cas de
conflit route stratégique qui conduit à
la frontière entre les deux corées à 50
mètres des mines antichars les paysans
nord coréens travaillent la terre
le régime communiste veut montrer qu'il
a confiance mais nous ne sommes pas
autorisés à leur parler la ligne de
partage entre les deux corées se résume
à trois barak bleus où se sont déroulés
les pourparlers avec les américains
étonnant face à face sur quelques
dizaines de mètres carrés se surveillent
en permanence soldats nord-coréens en
kaki soldats sud-coréens envers soldats
américains
pas de détente ici surtout depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de george bush aux
états unis quand nous entrons dans la
salle des pourparlers un soldat
sud-coréen nous observera sans scrupule
à travers la vitre la corée du nord
plaide aujourd'hui pour la réunification
avec le sud sous forme de confédération
elle entend bien garder son système
communiste elle a toujours besoin de
l'aide internationale mais reste
foncièrement contre le poids de
l'amérique dans la région les forces qui
empêche la réunification de la corée
sont les américains et les autorités sud
coréennes
les etats unis doivent rentrer chez eux
et retirer leurs armes et de la partie
sud de la corée les nord coréens font à
présent visiter ce bateau espions
américains capturés en 68 dans leurs
eaux territoriales
ils veulent humilier les états unis
alors qu'ils avaient placé beaucoup
d'espoir dans la politique de bill
clinton
et aujourd'hui les relations avec
l'amérique marque un temps d'arrêt
surtout depuis les déclarations de
george bush qui classe la corée du nord
parmi les pays de l'axé du mal
l'amérique dans continue par mois à
verser quelques 200 millions de dollars
dans les caisses de ce pays
mais les coréens du nord aujourd'hui
préfèrent dialoguer directement avec la
corée du sud
c'est peut-être là qu'est le grand
changement
dictature en famille puisque kim yong il
a pris la succession de son père il ya
huit ans à quelques points de repères il
règne sur un pays grand comme 20
départements français peuplée de 22
millions d'habitants où la famine et les
ravages mais où l'armée prospère un
homme en âge de travailler sur dix est
un militaire à leur tête donc celui
qu'on surnomme aussi le sauveur de
l'humanité
le dirigeant sacré kim yong-il despote
d'un autre âge
25000 c'était plutôt pour le dernier il
ya du monde
les teams devenait officiellement la
première ville 31 ans surnommé le cher
leader mais leur corps et âme aussi
redouter d'effets que les guitares ci
fait pareil mais aussi intelligent et
manipulateur il est dépossédé la cible
est à l'essai au beau jour dans d co
c'est capital de soitec et adoration et
les gens doutent il est né pour le
maquis pendant la guerre contre les
appeler et un double arc en ciel à
samuel eto'o qui est un génie
compositeur de six opéras citec de
plusieurs crans tout car le détail accor
de l'étranger de mathieu de contracter
l'inhabilité de débit fixe
et surtout c'est la corée du nord est le
leader courir la presse après les
visiteurs qui il a aussi été question
d'un autre état voyou entre guillemets
pour reprendre une terminologie
américaine la corée du nord qui elle
aussi de maîtriser le nucléaire est bien
le japon et l'australie ont décidé de
prendre des sanctions financières
la corée du nord dernière dictature
stalinienne accueillent les étrangers au
compte gouttes
notre envoyé spécial a pu suivre un
enseignant français là bas
des images rares reportage christian
ces coréens sont venus honorer leur
grand leader kim il sung comme à chaque
fête nationale une scène aujourd'hui
familière pour hervé de voulons à
pyongyang depuis neuf mois
il n'a pas oublié le choc de son premier
contact c'est très impressionnant votre
on arrive au départ
l'uniformité des vêtements l'absence de
voiture la largeur des rues vides
le noir la nuit les transports en commun
ou s'ils sont quand même sont assez
dégradés dont on voit les omnibus
en panne les gens qui attendent
déjà en marche beaucoup
après on s'habitue en fait cet
environnement et au départ c'est ça fait
presque un petit peu peur jeudi trois
fois par semaine l'unique professeur de
français en corée du nord donne ses
cours au lycée des langues étrangères
c'est sa seule occasion d'être en
contact avec les coréens le reste du
temps il vit seul dans un quartier
réservé aux étrangers
bonjour bonjour à ses mots sous le
regard de kim il sung et de son fils kim
jong-il début de la classe aujourd'hui
sujet d'étude
paris plages ses élèves étudient le
français depuis seulement quatre ans
pourtant ils ont déjà parfaitement
assimilé la grammaire mais pas seulement
l'apprentissage de la langue sert aussi
à relayer la propagande officielle
morceaux choisis nous allons travailler
librement
on n'a pas besoin de l'argent c'est
notre état qui s'occupe de lui sans le
généralissime tous mes sens nous soyons
traités comme des animaux par les
organismes et qu'est-ce qu'il ya un
sujet qu hervé devaux l'on se garde bien
d'évoquer d'ailleurs la présence de ce
professeur coréen qui assiste à tous ces
cours incite à la prudence de moi même
j'ai vite un certain nombre de tel
politique disons aux un peu trop
difficile à aborder
la france est le seul pays de l'union
européenne à ne pas avoir d' ambassadeur
en corée du nord
alors l'arrivée de ce français suscite
l'espoir d'une normalisation ici à
pignan en 25 ans le nombre de jeunes
north korea étudiants le français a été
divisé par six un déclin qui s'explique
sans doute par l'absence de relations
diplomatiques entre la république
populaire démocratique de corée et la
france et sept essais nucléaires
réalisés grâce selon pyongyang à une
technologie 100% dans coréenne souligne
un peu plus le décalage entre le pouvoir
mégalomaniaque des dirigeants et une
population dont une grande partie estime
le programme alimentaire mondial meurent
de faim alexandra marie le dictateur kim
jong il face à une parade militaire
voici une des rares images autorisées de
la corée du nord un régime stalinien
purs et durs fondée sur la propagande et
le culte de la personnalité
partout dans les rues de pyongyang des
statues monumentales à son effigie à
celle de son père kim il sung à qui il a
succédé il ya douze ans son règne a fait
de l'accord est un des pays les plus
fermés au monde
en l'absence de journalistes et
d'observateurs internationaux les 22
millions de nord coréens non
liberté de déplacement ni liberté
d'expression selon amnesty international
il serait même de plus en plus nombreux
à vouloir fuir car depuis plus de dix
ans le pays doit faire face à une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire
le régime mène une politique de
militarisation à outrance au détriment
du développement agricole
résultat depuis plus de dix ans le pays
est en proie à une crise alimentaire
très grave et même les ong ont des
difficultés à entrer dans le pays pour
le programme alimentaire mondial de ne
pas pouvoir assister des personnes dont
nous savons qu'elles ont besoin d' aide
le gouvernement persiste à dire qu'il va
s'occuper d'eux et j'espère que c'est
vrai mais depuis l'an dernier
nous savons que beaucoup de gens ont
besoin de nous selon les rares témoins
près de 40% des enfants souffrirait en
effet de malnutrition depuis des
dizaines d'années le pays survit grâce à
l'aide de ses rares partenaires
régionaux mais en défiant aujourd'hui la
communauté internationale la corée du
nord s'est exposé à des sanctions qui ne
feront qu'aggraver la situation du pays
l'une de nos équipes avaient pu entrer
en corée du nord il y à quelques il ya
un mois tout juste quelques jours
seulement avant cet essai elle avait
découvert un pays figé dans la terreur
et le culte de la personnalité
voici ce reportage signé christian
hottin et philippe denoyelle pyongyang
la mobilisation est permanente les
défilés quotidiens
ici exercice obligatoire pour des
étudiants malgré l'apparenté
tranquillité
la corée du nord est persuadé de vivre
sous la menace des états unis visite au
musée de la guerre et justification du
programme nucléaire ont forcé nucléaire
sans pas pour aubenas c'est notre hui
c'est pour nous protéger et protéger la
paix de la ces
en fait la paix qui monte ici nous
sommes dans le meilleur des mondes
le père éternel kim il sung veille sur
ces sujets douze ans après sa mort même
ceux qui ne l'ont pas connu le vénère il
est notre bonheur obligatoire au paradis
socialiste
le dernier régime stalinien de la
planète c'est au tour de 120 mètres de
haut symbolise l'esprit du défunt kim il
sung
chantre de l'autosuffisance construite
en un temps record pour fêter ses 60 ans
est mort hier en corée et dit toujours
que si le parti a la volonté on peut
tout faire
mais voici l'envers du décor la pénurie
faute d'électricité la capitale est
plongé dans le noir dès la nuit tombée
le régime prétend se suffire à lui-même
démonstration dans une ferme modèle à
quelques kilomètres de pyongyang
sur cette parcelle une dizaine de femmes
des herbes à la main un champ de navets
on nous assure qu'il y à 35 tracteurs
mais nous ne verrons que des deux
explications embarrassées
on a bien des tracteurs et toutes nos
machines ont été envoyés sur d'autres
exploitations qu'elle avait besoin alors
en attendant on doit désarmer à la main
à des gamins seule certitude le pays
dépend de l'aide internationale pour se
nourrir avec les nouvelles sanctions la
situation risque de s'aggraver
le principal pays donateurs la corée du
sud vient d'annoncer la réduction de son
nez malgré les mises en garde la corée
du nord a lancé sa fusée officiellement
pour mettre en orbite ce petit satellite
un prétexte pour masquer un essai de
missile capable d'atteindre l'alaska
le premier étage de la fusée s'est abîmé
en mer du japon le deuxième dans l'océan
pacifique après avoir survolé l'archipel
le troisième étage est tombé dans
l'océan lui aussi un peu plus tard
lancement était ratée mais la
provocation réussir réaction immédiate
de celui à qui ce défi est adressée en
tout premier le président américain les
règles doivent être respectées et les
violations doivent être punies
les mots ont un sens le monde entier
doit s'élever contre la prolifération
des césar car la corée du nord non
seulement possède des missiles mais
tente aussi de mettre au point une bombe
nucléaire
un régime communiste stalinien qui a
ruiné son pays et son peuple et qui se
comportent en hors la loi
je condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
cette provocation il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse c'est l'union de la communauté
internationale pour sanctionner un
régime qui ne respecte aucune des règles
internationales
une opinion partagée par le monde entier
la réprobation est unanime à l'exception
de la chine et de la russie qui appelle
à la retenue
les états unis et le japon ont demandé
une réunion d'urgence du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies réunion qui
va débuter dans quelques heures
c'est un fait exceptionnel des
journalistes ont pu filmer ce week-end
en corée du nord puis orient d'habitude
si hostile à toute présence étrangère
voulait manifestement mettre en scène
l'ascension de l'héritier le fils de kim
jong il
il a d'abord eu il ya d'abord eu une
grande parade militaire puis un moment
plus festif mais toujours sous très
bonne garde
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
nansha levons et sylvain tur
jamais bouquet final n'avait aussi bien
mérité son épilogue d'une journée
historique pour la corée du nord
celle où l'actuel leader kim jong-il a
présenté au peuple et au monde son
successeur désigné en la personne de son
propre fils kim jong-un troisième fils
donc accéder au pouvoir puisque son père
était lui-même le fils du fondateur de
cette dynastique du lys
alors les milliers de participants à ce
méga spectacle dont la corée du nord a
le secret ont mis les petits plats dans
les grands
pas une mèche de travers bazin pas
hésitant pas une faute de couleur il en
va de l'image du pays et de l'hommage au
vénéré dirigeants émotion une
participante
j'ai essayé de danser le mieux possible
mais j'étais stressé parce que kim jong
il me regardait
[Applaudissements]
le matin et spectacle était tout aussi
réglé au millimètre mais moins gracieux
pas de loi de rigueur vingt mille
soldats ont défilé dans une
démonstration de force adresser d'abord
aux ennemis d'une corée du nord qui se
considère encore en guerre avec sa
voisine du sud
ces missiles impressionnant et ses
mystérieux containers sont censés va
faire réfléchir ce défilé a
naturellement aussi un objectif
antérieur il veut montrer à la
population nord-coréenne que dans cette
période de transition encore une fois le
régime reste fort et que le dirigeant
désigné a le soutien de l'armée
[Musique]